fait et je vais vous dire monsieur
hanouna ya plein de l'endroit où j'ai
pas forcément mis les pieds à l'air
content que venir vous voir pour deux
raisons cioni nager vous dire c'est
quand on a peur du vent monte pas en
haut de l'arbre
1 et là moi j'ai envie de venir dans une
émission les gens vous regardent
ouais c'est tout sera le sujet
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
déjà jouer les cons je mets fin bat déjà
teintes elles mêmes qui coûte sarkozy
c'est toujours comme ça ben oui c'est
vrai
[Musique]
foughali sida
[Applaudissements]
k
ouf
c 'est
l'une fait sans péter les séries je sens
que la basse un peu lent mais cette fois
là bas c'est très très fort des voix
mais mais mais on aurait dû demander aux
gens qui vous savez imiter fait cela je
pense que cet après midi à des gens ton
équipe qui sont venu te voir et qui
t'ont 10 mai s'ils savent pas imiter la
personne qui en veut tu as dit on s'en
fout ils vont le faire quand même
je ne dis jamais on s'en fout barrette
syrie alors passionné enfin attendons ça
tourne son feutre bleu fait chacun boîte
mail pardon ça tourne sept russes alors
fait chacun votre meilleure imitation on
sait par exemple que chantal ce sera
zidane voilà si c'est en 2002 alors
l'attention des problèmes affalo l'oms
vas-y alors je passe mon tour pour des
raisons techniques s'est améliorée huit
ans à dalida
vas-y il venait d'avoir 18 ans il était
beau comme elle est en forme c'est en
fait je change pas d'invitation à la
plainte
je sais que je suis pris au jeu
[Applaudissements]
nous pensons que la pendule de landry
s'est arrêté sur mes dix jeunes et de
tragique
my back attention on m'a dit tous de
clara morgane vas-y à main franche est
un paradis mercury je sais faire
personne ne s'est pas fait du mercredi
un paria parce que c'est gad pas
meilleur est allé à meilleure assise
citadelle et vas-y et lydia que non mais
j'ai spécialistes préféré et li et kim
raconte il sourit il adorait cette
balise et c'est rebecca et sarah sont
sur un bol par toutes les deux étapes la
plaque au bout d'un moment et ben se
rapproche et pillent elle commence à
parler de leur intimité tu vois et voilà
pour le ghana une qui est utile sarah
louise y dis moi j'vais pas toi à ton
mari quand tu fais l'amour tu le
parcours à l'eau tout le dit m
emma quoi ça dépend s'ils m'appellent
sur un portable je lui réponds vicieux
[Applaudissements]
il a raison car tu peux pas le faire
après diane donc sa liste apparemment
vous coupez mais chantal voudraient
l'imiter comprendriez chantal te fais
super bien en fait dans le privé alors
si c'est vas-y vas-y tonton je fais très
bien à vous
même physiquement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
mais pourquoi tu me fais comme un singe
c'est buisson sebli sion je me semble
ici c'est quoi votre mii en éducation
géniale idée
vas-y oui c'est pas vrai c'est la
musique que j'aime c'est khaled al idée
je fais très bien fait vas-y ah j'en ai
un
après j'en ai un je lui ai dit gâtés
trésor je vend mieux que tout ça barroso
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
duris pis alors garde à quelqu'un
moi j'en ai un mais les plus jeunes qui
sont devant leur télé il faut leur dire
qu'ils étaient michel jonasz c'est le
jeune a 16 ans et la boîte de jazz est
là aussi je vais leur faire passer pas
sympa pour michel quand même pas ça sur
moi j'en ai un cyril oui c'est quoi
michel jonasz
j'adore ouais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ben 10
[Rires]
mais chantal voulons faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est
je te jure
et je me suis retourné
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est où et franchement pour moi le
vainqueur
elle est loin pas de bol on est tous
d'accord ici on le sait ses limites
je suis désolé mais je pense que cela va
marcher sur les plates-bandes c'est
surtout quand elle fait les volumes
étaient tournés ensemble on a tourné
avec claude et je me cachais comme
claude souvent le dos l'autre est celui
qui a réussi
[Rires]
vous pouvez pas vous pouvez pas le faire
toutes les deux temps non ce qu'on peut
faire de vachement mieux je vais te dire
un truc c'est par exemple chantal elle
vient là qui vont va se dire une phrase
et moi je me cache derrière et en fait
je le fais pas partie moi j'aimerais
bien voir des émissions
vas-y donc je te fais des trucs
j'aimerais pas le cul propre arbre
et ces jeux fait du playback on essaye
ça mon verger ravi kumar
et d'ailleurs je n'ai pas besoin de vous
raconter l'histoire pour avoir fait
cette émission c'était quelqu'un
derrière les séries la grosse rigolade
on l'a fait parce que un jour d'ailleurs
si michel boujenah jeu votre émission
qui m'avait raconté beaucoup blague on
s'est dit on va faire une émission où on
va et on va se réunir on va vous dis
donc ont cédé en fin d'émission avec
lolo c'est dire faire irruption avec des
mecs qui raconte aussi des blagues
lolo j'ai des courses chez que des
courtes c'est une femme elle pleure elle
est à la maternité elle pleure elle
regarde son bébé elle est en larmes elle
lui dit quand je pense qu'il ya neuf
mois j'ai faillite avaler
est-ce qu'on maintient sympa soit pas là
on va pas passer ma minute dessus
[Rires]
total est ce que tu as lu acte à droite
oui chameaux et un éléphant se
rencontrent pour la première fois ouais
alors est enfin aider pourquoi tu as de
nichons sur le dos aux chameaux elle
grandit en jeu
[Applaudissements]
le chameau ce biais toi pourquoi tel but
est alors c'est un ancien chauffeur de
bus qui prépare une excursion avec des
tétraplégiques lendemain donc il a un
train préparait son autobus
donc il enlève tous les sièges et aimé
des grosses barres pour attacher les
fauteuils roulants et tout donc il fait
ça toute la nuit et où le lendemain elle
va les chercher ils les monts qui les
attache très très bien et où il a un peu
en panique tout ça parfois crise et les
attaches bien et où ils y vont ils
commencent à rouler et roule doucement
parce qu'il a un peu peur donc il roule
doucement et là est tétraplégique sont
un peu utiles en vue dernier avoir un
peu de vitesse donc ils commencent à
chanter chauffeur si tu es champion
appui à puis chauffeur si tu es champion
appuyé sur le champignon et bien je fais
comment sont pas chauffées l'accélère un
petit peu mais ça ne suffit pas deux
gros party au ofer cité champignons puis
ça a tout la chanson geofin cité
champions champignons d'accord il
accélère encore mais ça leur va toujours
pas d'eau qui repart
[Musique]
si les champions puis sur un champignon
là le chauffeur comment s'énerver il
accélère et l'accélérer l'accélère il
rentre dans un platane il regarde le
chauffeur comme ça tous les trains en
gare de chauffeurs comme ça il a les
jambes encastrée dans l'ue